nos piden simplificar m al cubo elevado
al cuadrado dividido entre mx cúbica y
eso elevado a la cuarta y nos dicen
expresa tu respuesta en forma
exponencial nos indican que m es
distinto de 0 y x es distinto de 0 pues
si fueran iguales a 0 el denominador
sería 0 y la expresión no estaría
definida por eso nos dan esta
restricción de aquí de que ninguna de
ellas puede ser cero tratemos entonces
de simplificar esto para empezar lo voy
a reescribir el numerador es m al cubo
elevado al cuadrado y el denominador es
voy a usar un color distinto el
denominador es
m x x elevado al cubo y eso elevado a la
cuarta ahora trabajemos con estos de
manera independiente que resulta de
elevar m al cubo y luego elevarlo al
cuadrado bien si eleva salgo al cubo y
después lo eleva al cuadrado eso va a
ser igual lo voy a poner por acá esto es
m a la 3 por 2 m3 por 2 y m elevado a la
sexta potencia elevamos semi al cubo y
eso lo elevamos al cuadrado pues si te
fijas bien esta expresión déjame ponerlo
aquí al lado si tenemos m al cubo
elevado al cuadrado y aquí no hay ningún
tipo de magia es simplemente matemática
veamos esto sería m al cubo multiplicado
por sí mismo otra vez por m al cubo y
aquí tienes dos veces el exponente 3 si
fuera m al cubo a la cuarta entonces
estarías multiplicando cuatro veces el
exponente 3 es por eso que esto es m al
3 por 2
así es que en el numerador tenemos m a
la sexta y en el denominador tenemos m
por x al cubo elevado a la cuarta
potencia en general cuando tienes el
producto de dos número
elevado a una potencia puedes elevar
cada uno de esos números a la potencia y
después hacer el producto por lo que
este denominador va a ser entonces m a
la cuarta
x x al cubo elevado a la cuarta lo único
que estoy haciendo es elevar m a la
cuarta y x al cubo elevarlo a la cuarta
y ahora cómo podemos simplificar esto el
numerador es m a la sexta ese sigue
siendo m a la sexta dividido entre m a
la cuarta
m a la cuarta que multiplica a x al cubo
elevado a la cuarta podemos aquí
multiplicar los exponentes para obtener
x elevado a la 12 x elevado a la 12
ahora tenemos m a la sexta dividido
entre me a la cuarta y esto lo puedes
ver como m a la sexta por m a la menos 4
o podríamos hacer la simplificación pero
nosotros sabemos espero que sepamos que
esto de aquí este cociente de aquí lo
podemos simplificar como m elevado a las
6 menos 4 así es que esto es igual a m
al cuadrado esto es m 64 y aún tenemos
en el denominador x a la 12 aún tenemos
x a la 12 así es que esto está dividido
entre x a la 12 y ya hemos concluido
ahora si no queremos tener esta
expresión en el denominador este x a la
12 del denominador podemos pasarlo al
numerador como x a la menos 12
esto sería igual entonces a m cuadrado
que ya tenemos y este x a la 12 la
podemos poner el numerador como x a la
menos 12 cualquiera de estas dos es una
respuesta válida